what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and there have been a lot of talks
recently about Robert Downey Jr
returning to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and even though we are in The
multiversal Saga and variants are a very
real thing right now there are still
other ways that Robert Downey Jr could
return besides being a variant of
himself but obviously of course a big
one would be Robert Downey Jr returning
an Avengers Secret Wars as an actual
variant of himself returning as Tony
Stark From Another Universe recently we
heard some reports that Spider-Man is
going to be the leader of the Avengers
moving forward with Kang Dynasty so I
think it would be really cool if a
version of Tony Stark played by Robert
Downey Jr showed up in secret Wars so we
could have that moment that emotional
moment for at least Peter Parker to see
his mentor once again who of course is
gone so let's make it clear that Tony
Stark isn't being revived he's not
coming back to life in some magical way
we're talking about him showing up as a
variant of himself or in some type of
hologram possibly in the Iron Heart
series or maybe even armor Wars there
have been a lot of rumors going around
about his return and recently Jonathan
Majors who plays Kang in the MCU now has
commented that he would love to act with
Robert Downey Jr and he would love to
see Kang and Iron Man interact now
recently a Marvel Studios executive
commented on Robert Downey Jr no longer
being a part of the MCU and I think a
lot of people are misunderstanding what
he said a lot of people have took what
this person said as a no Robert Downey
Jr will never come back to reprise his
role as Tony Stark or a variant in any
way whatsoever however that is not what
he meant so there is still hope that
Robert Downey Jr could return and make
at least a cameo so let's break down
this new report in an interview with i09
Marvel Studios VP of production and
development Steven brassard talked about
the new generation of Heroes stepping to
the Forefront in Phase 4 5 and 6. and in
this interview he said Robert Downey
Jr's Iron Man is no longer on the table
and a lot of people assumed this meant
that Robert Downey Jr is no longer on
the table to return for a cameo in the
MCU at all ever again however let's take
a look at what he said he said well I
think one of the meta narratives of
phase four was about new characters it
was about new people stepping into
mantles if you look at like Cassie Lang
and quantumania getting a suit in Kate
bishop and Hawkeye new characters being
introduced like Jack and werewolf by
Knight after these first 10 years of
Marvel storytelling torches are being
passed like with Robert Downey Jr no
longer being on the table and stuff like
that so it was kind of like a new
generation stepping to the Forefront
which again has always happened in the
comics so as you can see here in this
interview he is not saying that Robert
Downey Jr can't ever return in a cameo
like fashion where he plays a variant of
himself or perhaps a hologram or AI all
he was doing is stating that in Phase 4
and Phase 5 when this new saga begun
Iron Man was off the table because he
died in Avengers end game so don't take
what he said as him saying he can't
return because that isn't what he's
saying at all in fact if we've learned
anything from the comics it's that
characters can definitely return in some
way shape or form and several Insider
accounts online have even stated that
they do expect to see Robert Downey Jr
in Avengers Secret Wars and this just
makes sense and it does kind of line up
with some things that we've heard Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios is
actually going to do and also not to
mention there's been a lot of talk
recently that Superior Iron Man
specifically Tom Cruise as Superior Iron
Man could show up in secret Wars as well
but let's take a look at what they're
doing for Deadpool 3. at this point in
time it's pretty much confirmed that the
old X-Men are going to be returning
after all we already do have Hugh
Jackman returning so hearing that other
X-Men are going to be returning as well
isn't that much of a surprise and
according to Grace Randolph Kevin feige
is also going to bring back the original
X-Men not only in Deadpool 3 but also in
Avengers Secret Wars as well and she
states that the reason that he wants to
do this is so that they can get a proper
goodbye in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
keep in mind Kevin feige started his
Marvel career with the first X-Men film
in 2000 and then he worked on all of the
X-Men movies that came after that so
they are his start and many of the X-Men
the original X-Men actors have expressed
that they wish they could have been a
part of the MCU well it looks like Kevin
feige is making their dreams come true
he's making them a part of the MCU and
giving them their final goodbye so they
can finally say a true goodbye to their
characters after Secret Wars Now Kevin
feige bringing back Robert Downey Jr's
Iron Man wouldn't exactly be for a
goodbye we already got a goodbye with
Avengers end game Tony Stark got a whole
funeral and Natasha got well nothing so
Robert Downey Jr Junior returning in
secret Wars would kind of Simply Be for
fan service and its fan service that I
think a lot of people would like because
it doesn't actually negate anything it
doesn't take away from the death of Iron
Man in Avengers end game they're not
undoing his death by having him return
as a variant rather they could actually
give us some pretty interesting scenes
like I mentioned our Spider-Man could
see a Tony Stark variant and get very
emotional over it and recently Jonathan
Majors like I said expressed his
interest in acting with Robert Downey Jr
and having Kang go up against Iron Man
here's what he said in a recent
interview with Lifehacker in regards to
Iron Man and Ken going up against each
other possibly in the future he said I
would love to be across from him on
screen to see how our philosophies
acting wise and character-wise just
personally match up you know I find him
to be such a fascinating artist which is
why Iron Man is so fascinating his
portrayal of Iron Man is so fascinating
and he represents a very clear world
view and in energy of the Avengers and I
think Kang represents a different era
and he ended it by saying it'd be really
interesting to see those two kind of
come together and have a bit of
conversation so Jonathan Majors who
plays the big bad of this entire Saga
wants Robert Downey Jr to return as Iron
Man but of course like we've been saying
not undo his death simply as a variant
and speaking of variance there has been
a lot of talk recently and this is just
a rumor for now but there has been a lot
of talk recently about Tom Cruise
possibly appearing as Superior Iron Man
In Secret Wars according to the rumor
mill again not confirmed we could be
getting a major scene with Superior Iron
Man who isn't exactly a good Iron Man In
Secret Wars now most of us know that Tom
Cruise was almost Iron Man before Robert
Downey Jr so it would be really cool to
see him as Superior Iron Man we thought
we were going to get it and Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness but
instead we just got what looked to be
superior carrier Iron Man Ultron Bots
although they could be from Reed but if
we do get a Tom Cruise Cameo as Superior
Iron Man it makes us wonder if we still
will get a Robert Downey Jr Cameo it
most certainly is possible to get a
cameo from both of them in fact it would
be good to show that variants can differ
so much that some are good and some are
bad that would be really cool and it
would be really good fan service and if
you think well Marvel probably won't do
that just for the fan service well
that's exactly what they did in Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness and
the president of Marvel Studios Kevin
feige basically confirmed that that he
did it essentially for fan service he
did it for the fans he thought it would
be cool so this is entirely possible it
is entirely in Marvel's realm but the
best part of it is that it makes actual
sense Secret Wars is going to be all
about the Multiverse and different
heroes from other universes it would
actually make sense to see an Iron Man
variant in the movie and luckily for us
nobody at Marvel Studios has said that
it's off the table so I hope this
cleared things up for you and although
it's not confirmed I hope everybody is
excited about the potential of Robert
Downey Jr possibly returning as a cameo
in Avengers Secret Wars but let me know
your thoughts about all of this in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf